Okay, so we are back at the screen.
Welcome to video 33, where we're now going
to be looking at the Trade Idea Template.
There is a download accompanied to this
video, the Trade Idea Template Word
document. So please download that when we
go into the details of the Trade Idea
Template.
But first, before we get into that, we
have to set the scene. As a quick
reminder, you should be very familiar with
this now, the ProTrader Systematic
Process, Long Short Portfolio Management
with a 20 to 60 day time horizon.
And you should be well briefed by now that
the Trade Idea Generation Process is not
just fundamentals, it's fundamentals plus
timing,
plus trade structure around catalysts. Now
at this juncture, it's worth pointing out
what trade structuring actually is.
So what are we actually referring to when
we mention trade structuring? We've
alluded to some basics in the past, but at
this juncture, we just have to cement the
definition before we move on.
What we're essentially referring to is
options structures that fit the trade idea
that you've just come up with.
So the trade idea that you've just
generated. But you have to remember a
trade idea is not fully complete without
catalysts and even your trade structure.
So before you look at catalysts and
potential trade structure. So before you
look at catalysts and potential trade
structures, what you've actually got is
what you consider to be a fundamental long
or short idea.
However, it's not fully a trade idea.
However, it's not fully a trade idea yet
at that stage. You need catalyst
identification, which is going to bias
your trade structure.
So when you've been through the first part
of the trade idea generation process and
you've decided that a stock is either a
fundamental long or a short, and then
you've actually identified catalysts.
Well, at that stage, as traders, we have
choices in how we structure the trade. So
we can go longer stock, we can buy a stock
or we can short stock outright in a cash
for stock transaction.
So that is an outright position. There's
no leverage here. All we can do this on
margin. So for example, in the United
States, where you can have a 50% overnight
margin requirement that would be
leveraging.
Your margin two for one. But essentially,
you're either owning the stock or shorting
the stock, you're just leveraged two for
one 50% margin requirements.
Or if you're an international guy, and you
can access contracts for difference on
your brokerage platform CFDs, you're not
actually going long the stock or shorting
the stock, you're taking a position in a
derivative instrument called a CFD.
And you can get up to five times leverage,
and you can get up to five times leverage
at this moment in time. But more
realistically, on average, you're looking
at four times leverage.
On top of that, and this is accessible by
both US and international traders, we can
opt for a plethora of directional stock
options structures.
So we're not taking a position outright in
the stock or on margin in the stock or
leveraging up using derivative instruments
like CFDs.
What we're doing is we're using derivative
instruments called stock options.
Now, for the purposes of the PTM video
series, we are not going to be covering
these structures as we've mentioned
previously in the video series.
Why? Because it's a lot of work additional
to what we're covering in the PTM video
series.
Learning all of the directional option
structures that are utilized on a
continual basis by pro level traders, that
is an entire video series in itself.
And that's covered in our professional
options trading masterclass video series.
So completing the PTM video series is
essential for learning how to do this.
We highly recommend that you complete the
PTM video series after you've completed
the IPLT and PTM video series.
But what's important to understand here is
that everything you're learning in the PTM
video series assumes that in the end, you
will be taking a long or short stock
position,
either outright or on margin or via CFD.
Now, as a side note, when it comes to
timing as part of the overall trade idea
generation process, don't worry, we will
be coming to this a little later in the
PTM video series.
So at this stage, it's worth understanding
the background of where we've come from
and where we've arrived.
So let's go through the entire trade idea
generation process and look at each video
that's covered each area of the trade idea
generation process.
What we've actually covered and what steps
we actually took, because these are the
steps you're going to be taking.
So we started out introducing you to the
quantitative phase with video 22, quant
processing one, and we were looking at
forward looking valuation.
Then with video 23, quant processing two,
we were looking at forward looking growth.
So our growth metrics like earnings growth
and revenue growth.
Then in video 24, quant processing three,
we were looking at forward growth ratings.
So specifically peg ratio and looking at
backwards looking quantitative supporting
statements.
In video 25, quant processing four, we
looked at specifically the actual
mechanics of long trade ideas.
And we were looking at and focusing on the
subset of earnings growth profiles for
long position optimization.
And then in video 26, quant processing
five, we looked at the flip side of that,
the mechanics of short ideas.
So earnings growth profiles that are
optimal for short position ideas.
Then in video 27, quant processing six, we
looked at for diversification purposes,
turnarounds and value traps and how we
treat them.
Then in video 27, fully recognizing along
the way that these are suboptimal yet
necessary earnings growth profiles for
portfolio diversification of ideas.
Then in video 28, quant processing seven,
we looked at the common data mining and
processing mistakes that most retail
traders will experience in the outset when
they're starting out.
And we went through these to ensure that
you can perfect the quant processing stage
quicker and more efficiently in your
educational development.
And then in video 29, we recapped the
entire quantitative process and we put
everything together so you better
understand the entire process.
Then we moved on to the qualitative
assessment where we started looking at key
performance indicators, KPIs.
So we looked at essentially the business
drivers behind the growth rates of a
company as in what is actually driving the
business and the valuation.
And from that we infer a management
operating plan.
In video 31, qualitative assessment two,
we started tying up the loose ends of the
qualitative.
So we end up doing a quality assessment
and we gauge the parameters of market
expectations and the range for those
expectations.
And then in video 32, we covered the key
ingredient that we have to add to our
trade idea generation process for a
fundamental long or short potential trade
idea actually becoming a trade idea.
And that is definable catalysts, catalyst
identification.
What are we doing there?
We're assessing management communication
and what can potentially move the needle
in between earnings reports.
And now we've arrived at video 33, the
trade idea generation template.
So the question is here.
Why do we even bother with a trade idea
generation template in the first place?
Well, it's about discipline and it's about
consistency.
The entire trade idea generation process
that you see here on the screen and what
we've covered in the PTM video series for
that process up to this point.
Everything goes in the trade idea
generation template for every idea that
you generate.
If you do this going forward for every
trade idea that you come up with, you're
going through essentially a discipline of
a checklist.
You are formalizing the process into a
consistent format.
The more you do it, the more familiar you
will become with the process and the
better you will become at it.
And even when you become good at it, you
need to keep doing it out of discipline.
You need to engage in this discipline
regularly on repeat forever.
Because regularity and familiarity breeds
consistency.
Consistency in process leads to
consistency in returns.
Now, of course, we've called this slide
here the entire trade idea generation
process.
Of course, you may actually be generating
trade ideas from macro indicators.
But primarily, the macroeconomic
indicators, the leading indicator
dashboard, primarily this is for
establishing a portfolio bias.
But yes, of course, macro indicators for
diversification purposes in your portfolio
at any one time may actually be driving
some of your trade ideas that you have in
your portfolio.
But for the majority of your trade ideas,
you're going to be going through the trade
idea generation process at the micro level
and going through the quantitative and
qualitative dashboard.
And you can see here now on the right hand
side, we filled out at this stage all of
our qualitative metrics.
So we've added our earnings call
transcripts, our management track record,
the board of directors assessment, insider
stock and stock option ownership
assessment, and the transaction history,
and the lay of the land in terms of
analyst estimates, the range and the
ratings.
And our essential ingredient to define a
trade idea catalysts.
So in the majority of cases, in terms of
trade idea generation, you are going to be
generating ideas utilizing the bottom up
micro assessment, going through the
quantitative and qualitative processes.
So identification via quantitative with
supporting evidence at the sector level
and drilling down to find positive and
negative outliers, and then doing
qualitative work on those outliers.
And when you do all of this, you're going
to neatly, efficiently, and optimally, on
repeat, fill out the trade idea template.
So go to the downloads area of this video,
download the word document, the trade idea
template.
We've saved this as a word document, so
you can actually use it as a template.
And you can actually delete areas of
information within the word document and
replace this, obviously, with new data,
therefore new ideas.
And you'll see that there's various
different areas of the trade idea
template, which when you look at each of
those areas, you will realize that each of
those areas is a part of the trade idea
generation process.
And what we're going to do here is run
through an example for you so you
understand how to use it properly.
So the example that we're going to run
through is with the company or stock
called Zendesk.
And we're going to start with the first
stage, which is the quantitative analysis.
And we're going to look at the data as a
case study of what this would have looked
like in May 2020.
So imagine you've been through your
spreadsheet work, the quantitative work at
this stage, and now you're moving that
data over to the word document, the trade
idea generation template.
So you can see here for Zen, Zendesk, the
fields we have in the word document.
We have the stock price, market cap,
earnings per share estimates, and reported
earnings per share.
We have earnings growth, price earnings
ratio, peg ratio.
We also have sales in millions of dollars,
sales growth percentage, so sales growth,
sales multiple, and we have net income.
What we also denote here in the first part
of our template is the shares outstanding
at the time.
So what are we actually trying to achieve
in this first part of the trade idea
generation template?
Well, in this part of the template, what
we're aiming to do is we're aiming to get
the numbers right
and to arrive at sensible and reasonable
conclusions in terms of price target
assumptions.
Now you'll notice a few things in the
table that are worth talking about here,
where you see the letter E denoted.
These are forward-looking estimates,
numbers based off forward-looking
estimates that are important to us,
that we denote in terms of moving forwards
for our expectations of the stock price.
Also, for stock prices in the table before
or previous to 2020, we have taken the
stock price at the end of each year and
just rounded to the nearest dollar.
So the thing to bear in mind here as you
go through these processes is that this is
obviously not an exact science.
We just need to make our template and our
quantitative as accurate as possible and
make reasonable assumptions
so we can derive an expected stock price
move and the parameters that we're
operating in moving forward.
Now you'll notice also that there's some
commentary under the table in the trade
idea generation template.
Some commentary on the annual quantitative
analysis here.
So when you're going through your
processes, this part of the template is
intended for you to literally spell out
what type of trade this is.
And also to have your price targets listed
in this area.
Because your price targets are inferred by
the quantitative data.
So the growth numbers and the valuation.
So if we look at the basic commentary
around Zendesk here underneath the table.
When you were doing your quantitative work
at the time, you will have concluded that
Zendesk is much more of a revenue growth
story rather than an earnings growth
story.
So you will have covered this in this
section of the trade idea generation
template.
Obviously to remind yourself of the actual
situation in the stock.
What type of trade that it is.
So in 2019, we know that Zendesk booked a
gap loss and a non-gap profit.
So it's a much more of a revenue growth
story.
In 2019, the gap loss was at minus one
hundred and sixty nine point seven million
dollars.
And a non-gap profit they booked as thirty
six point eight million dollars.
And the difference was due to a share
based compensation package or scheme.
And it was related to expenses to do with
that.
So we are operating here.
Utilizing the non-gap profit numbers.
Because we are working off a positive EPS
number.
Now we're not going to go into all the
accounting minutiae here.
In what situations you should be looking
at gap and non-gap numbers.
That's additional work that you'll have to
do outside the scope of the PTM video
series.
Now you can see here in the comments
section.
We have reference to our end of the
financial year 2020 price targets.
And what we're doing here is using the
same PE moving forward as 2019.
So we're assuming that the market pays
roughly the same multiple for earnings
going forward.
So one thing we do to get a price target
is we look at the 2020 EPS number versus
the 2019 EPS number.
And we work out the difference between the
two.
So the percentage difference, which of
course is earnings growth for 2020 versus
2019.
And we work out the earnings growth number
as a multiple, which is 1.8.
So all we're doing here in reality is
basically saying that if the stock
actually delivers on 80% earnings growth.
If we keep the multiple, the PE ratio
constant and valuation constant, then the
stock price is likely to be up around a
similar amount.
So up 80%.
So the stock price moves from $76 to $136.
And instead of getting carried away here
and calling this a totally realistic
expectation, what we do is, is we call
this our upper bound.
So our upper bound price target is
basically a very bullish expectation.
Now, as we have this 2020 price target of
$136.80 to be specific as our upper bound,
we can use that number to multiply by the
shares outstanding to get an inferred
market capitalization for the upper bound
at the end of 2020.
And this comes in at $15.1 billion.
And then we can divide that number by the
sales estimate of the market of $1.1
billion.
And that gives us an upper bound sales
multiple for the end of 2020 at 13.74.
Now, as we know, in this situation,
Zendesk is more of a revenue growth story.
So we can utilize sales numbers and sales
multiples to come up with a lower bound
price target.
So if we utilize the consensus mean sales
estimate from analysts for 2020, which is
$1.1 billion, we can multiply this by the
sales multiple of 2019, 10.31, keeping
that constant into 2020.
And then we can divide by shares
outstanding to get to a lower bound price
target of $102.60 based on our sales
estimates and sales multiples.
So what we've done here is we've achieved
an upper bound bullish price target based
on forward looking earnings and constant
valuation.
So what we've done here is we've achieved
a lower bound price target based on sales
and sales multiples staying constant.
Now, just as a side note here, as
mentioned earlier, we're not going to
delve into the details of commenting on
gap and non-gap.
This is a situational scenario to Zendesk.
And this is where discretion,
discretionary interpretation of each
individual situation occurs.
But it should be pretty obvious in this
situation with Zendesk, for example, that
the market is choosing to focus on the
revenue growth story.
And the evidence is in the valuation that
the market is willing to pay for the
revenue growth and the maturation or
maturing of a company going from a loss
making operation at the earnings level.